hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar creating and maintaining
and effective and efficient in vivo
surgical training programs I in
Christian amolik lepers and I'll be
moderating the session his educational
web seminar is presented by lab roots
from reading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtue elements in webinars advancing
scientific collaboration am learning to
do the horns visit libraries com let's
get started you can have questions to
the speakers during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them in the Q&A box which
will open when you put on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the side window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support button down at the
top right of a presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button as a lower left of the
screen this is an educational web
seminar that's in offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over police put on this PE button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credit it is my
pleasure to introduce today's speaker
Matthew legal surgical research
specialist senior associate scientist in
vivo Resource Center biogen Matt entered
this research field in terms of research
field over 24 years ago as
a lab animal surgical technician at the
TSI Mason contact research facilities
since then he has worked at contact
facilities such st SI ando read bio
safety as well as end up in industry at
pharmacia pfizer jin sign sanofi-aventis
and Biogen during that period he has
performed a variety of surgical
procedures including device implantation
and plantations trans transplants
orthopaedic defect ocular vascular
implants cardiac surgery and brain and
spinal procedures his experience ranges
from mice and rest to non-human primates
and livestock in addition he holds four
patents of novel surgical devices in
implants and have trained over 900
technicians scientists veterinarians in
positions in surgical techniques and
procedures for over 20 years she has
also taught several webinars for the
veterinary BIOS Science Institute
including a three-part rodent
stereotactic surgery at 14 parts surgery
for technicians courses outside of the
surgical realm he has been a study
director Adele cardiograph ER safety
pharmacologist scientist and manager
currently math supervises a team of
associates at biogen to conduct surgical
and non-surgical studies along with
being the lead surgical trainer for all
in vivo staff Matt was on the board of
the directors of the tiniest surgical
research for over ten years serving as
the program chair for three of them as
well as educational chair for two
currently he's the program chairman for
the New England branch of a lab mr.
Freegal will now begin his presentation
the floor is yours
alright um just before we get started I
would like to say thank you very much to
the organizers for giving me this
opportunity to talk about something that
is very near and dear to my heart and
also all the people who are taking time
out from heaven hometown very busy days
to attend watch and hopefully ask a lot
of really good questions throughout the
course of this presentation so I've got
a lot to talk about so let us get
started um we're going to be talking
about training programs and in my
opinion training programs are some of
the most critical aspects of what we do
when it comes to in vivo work within our
Bavaria their critical if you do the
techniques well then you tend to get
good data good scientific assessments
out of it you can move your drugs to
market you can move your devices forward
you can continue your basic research and
come up with things that will be useful
for we as a few however one of the
things that we frequently struggle with
is we often have teachers and
instructors who don't have any formal
training in teaching if something that
we wouldn't let I would not be happy if
my daughter when she was in kindergarten
was getting training from someone with
no experience in teaching we do that all
the time in this field up to and
including cardiovascular surgery
transplants what makes it a little bit
more difficult is surgery covers a whole
number of areas that covers anesthesia
it covers a septic technique with tissue
and billing etc etc we have to cover a
lot when we're teaching our students so
I'm going to talk for the majority this
presentation on how you put together
your training programs that it functions
as effectively as possible and it's
going to be a series of questions really
that you need answer and my biggest
piece of advice to anyone doing this to
your homework answer your questions
first and then design your program and
many of us if not all of us who've been
involved in these types of training
programs
we've all experienced that rather
dubious choice of you don't have time to
do that or at least you don't feel that
you have time to do that so you start a
program and then you're desperately
trying to fix it and tweak it sometimes
for years if you can give yourself that
time maybe even only a week or two
answer these questions first the program
that you put into place will probably be
pretty good you won't require a lot of
your very valuable and very scarce time
to make the improvements that you need
for the function properly so it's
depended on a bunch of things what are
the regulations and guidelines who are
you teaching what the resources you have
what's the training staff if you have
make a realistic assessment of all of
those don't guess don't make your this
doesn't look good if I admit following
be realistic because you're going to be
stuck working with all of these
regardless of whether you're willing to
admit it or not regulations and
guidelines we've all read them we have
internalized okies we have guidance
documents we have various federal
regulations and guidelines are you a
lack certified so on and so forth that's
only the first step how are they apply
to your facility what are the
expectations to work in your live area
and then how are they applied in student
flat out if every student's lab held to
the same standard do they have the same
functionality do they have the same SOPs
they probably differ from each other and
you need to know that so that you can
prepare your students properly as a
trainer is a training group what's your
authority what's your responsibility the
people have to listen to you can you
just lay down the law or are you going
to have to convince and bring people
along and build up more of a bond of
trust be able to get your students to do
things properly or the gray areas
identify those develop a proactive plan
don't wait for things to go wrong
because then you're desperately
scrambling to make
chances are it's not going to be nearly
as good as if you took the time at the
outset and identify the areas that
questions may arise from come up with
your answers what are your response is
going to be documentation required are
you document your training program who's
going to be looking at what are you
going to be using it for your students
are you training what are their
backgrounds are you training physicians
are you training technicians are you
training people with 20 years of
experience or two months experience
what's your scientific background um
some of the best surgeons I have ever
trained I hired directly out of facility
operations out of cage watch they were
fantastic but they might not have the
scientific background that your PhD
students have you mean they can't be
outstanding surgeons but it means you're
going to have to teach them in a more
involved fashion and probably a little
bit more give them resources with their
interest your students want to be there
and we'll talk about that a little bit
but interest is so important and if you
haven't take a program up to take into
account whether your students want to be
there or not you may well fail um what's
their relative position in the
organization I've had people who came in
who were bp's I really can't tell a BP
once again there's a power disparity
there it doesn't mean that you can be an
effective teacher it doesn't mean that
they can't be a very effective student
but hierarchy does matter who are you
going to be faced with your students
availability can you get the ninja
training how often are they there are
they running a phase for nine hours a
day four days a week how much can you
get ahold of it how much can they be in
that training room here's the point the
student isn't point everything in this
program that you're going to be putting
together or administering depends on now
if you don't have students and they're
not learning properly then your program
is a failure it's not accomplishing
anything what are their needs and how
can you meet them and again be realistic
I'll try not to repeat that too many
times moving forward keep it in the back
of your head always be realistic even if
only to yourself admit what you're going
to be dealing with and develop realistic
approaches to handling of your students
understand their motivation because all
of this event on that all of us have
been the person getting trained many of
us are still getting trained on things
um put yourself in their head there any
great pressure to produce they were
sired to produce study data they were
hired to execute these procedures and
they're under a tremendous amount of
pressure to do so and that leads to
anxiety the group is looking at the boss
wants them to be working a week ago the
constantly asking where you left how are
you doing when can you start working on
study um those of us who obey been
experienced surgeons there's a real
anxiety that comes in because now all
the stuff that you said when you were
your interview I have to back up and
your students are in that same position
they have to back up everything that
they said if they said I'm an
outstanding Brodin surgeon now have to
prove it that's a tremendous amount of
anxiety they don't want to fail they may
be in a completely different situation
did their previous place hold them to a
higher standard lower standards to
different standard all that is laying on
because he only wants to be embarrassed
no one has to admit failure or struggles
especially to their new boss especially
to their new group for many surgeons
certainly many that I've trade it won't
want to be searched slender gold they
didn't go to school concerts wasn't a
driving goal from the time that they
were childhood they want to be
biochemists they want to be an
oncologist they want to research new
forms of attacking fibrosis and want to
tackle Alzheimer's surgery is just a
tool it's just a way for them to
accomplish their research that
passionate their research methodology
that they're using
get there they're also not in control of
their own process right we're
controlling it to a large extent and set
up the structure they have to work with
us and that's anxiety provoking because
now they're putting their whole career
in the hands of us and they probably
don't know it probably never met before
they started this training probe so
they're completely dependent on someone
they don't know if no idea if we're good
at what we do they have no ideas with
these in the surgeons there no mercy
that's anxiety provoking some of the
steps that I use be mystified yeah
surgery is an art it's an achievable art
all right I tend in my training sessions
to gullet organic chemistry chemistry
apologies organic carpentry we're taking
things apart we're putting them together
they just happen to be biologic instead
of a piece of inert wood or some other
material if your students have these a
hand eye coordination relatively stable
in and is willing to learn is engaged in
the process you can teach them surgery
oh and that engage sprayed is going to
compensate for a walk I put down there
and that's a Enda size and mass Tamela
sees but one of my students did right
out of case watch they did a fantastic
job I have video I apologize it and put
it in and watch pulsating beautiful
again he nest affiant here we talk about
things we're going to do a myocardial
infarction amounts we're going to do a
kidney transplant and we as surgeons are
really invested in convincing everyone
that what we do is unbelievably
complicated complex like God where the
elite no one to do what we do really we
tell people that don't even bother
making the attack you can't do it it's
so hard we're so good really take
myocardial infarction to make an
incision in the chest with scissors
maybe a scalpel depending on the size of
the animal I'm going to make an incision
be between the ribs I'm going to retract
the ribs
we can identify the heart-opening sighs
Eric cardium so basically at this point
I've done retraction and I made
incisions to skills will stabilize the
heart let's be chaired one call that a
third skill I'm going to put a suture
around the coronary artery okay suturing
and then I'm going to close the tissues
behind me with serious by their single
interrupted continuous suck you take
your etc so I've made incisions at done
tissue retraction I place sutures re
skills and yes there is that principles
there's entities and cheese here that
you make incisions you're dissecting
yeah there are other things in it but at
its core that's a really small number of
things that your student has to learn if
they take the time if they use that
admittedly fairly limited set of
surgical skills that covers a lot of
procedures so long as it won't focus
they have the intent and they're willing
to practice the art of surgery where
experience comes in where higher level
training comes in it's knowing when to
take those basic techniques of how to
apply them come modify them when to
modify them but if the early stages just
a series of basic techniques what are
your resources your instructors your
facilities your equipment the animals
let's practice on them what protocols do
you have what are your supplies or your
references and I'm going to talk about
references a fair amount because those
can really save you a tremendous amount
of time so for your instructors basic
questions but i'll tell you i've put
together programs before I thought to
address these it cost me it cost you
dearly and it made it so much more
difficult for myself and the other
instructors how many can have no really
how many do you have not hypothetically
there's 50 people in your group who can
do it realistically how many can you
call them realize it what's your
background um I've been teaching surgery
for very long time some days it seems
longer than others
I was training new technicians on basic
surgical procedures when I have been in
the field for a little bit less than
three years I didn't know what I was
doing I was perfectly capable
demonstrating what I did that's not
teaching I'm just showing them what I do
when hoping that they pick it up um so
background is what their experience
oftentimes in these fields we have new
techniques we have people who we have to
validate for a procedure we've never
done how are you going to address that
is that gonna come up are they any good
as trainers there are bad trainers out
there many of us were at best mediocre
train hopefully we learned that over the
years there watching bad trainers over
out there there lots of mediocre ones
there lots of them that are too
stretched up you can still use them and
you can use them effects with the answer
that at the outset that drives a lot of
your structure because here's the thing
teaching is a crowd it requires work it
requires training requires your
self-evaluation evaluation of others on
the time you're doing mental flexibility
willingness to itself it is hard work to
be a good teacher and it can have a good
trainer a good instructor out there they
weren't born fully formed from the head
of Zeus they had to learn it they had to
focus on it it is a crap but if you want
to be a good teacher you're going to
have to work at it forever it never ends
you can always be better and in this
field we tend to we don't pick trainers
because of teaching skills we picked
them because they are the best person in
the lab to do a procedure this person
can do a carotid artery cannulation all
on a 18 grand Mouse better than they
want to see that means they can teach it
doesn't mean that they can explain what
they're doing just being technically
they're very strong these are two
different skill sets it's good to have
both but a lot of times we rely on the
technical skill set and not the teaching
skill set are you teaching your
instructors how to teach
are you training your trainers if you're
putting together new program certifies
the first trainer who says this is the
person who can teach everybody else
chicken in the egg you have a certain
someone to answer these questions and be
realistic in your assessment of your
teaching pool some instructors are Yoda
some instructors are Kenobi your star
wars fan you know how well that worked
out so be realistic you can set up
structure to counterbalance Oh we'll
talk about that in a bit but systematize
your teacher evaluations have a process
have a forum have a survey have a way to
go back to your training how did things
work you check on them six months later
think about these things and put them
into your structure use metrics as I've
gotten older so many of the corporate
buzzwords that I used to laugh at has
actually started to make sense entirely
sure that says about me as I've
continued in the field but there are
reasons metrics or there's a reason
their way to evaluate how things are
going how your performance is going
simple ones from sign off pine from
initiation columns venting can you get
that time down how many post-training
complications dear students help you
track that or do you sign them off and
wish them well and hopefully that maybe
that's okay you don't have the resources
to track that what you may be in a
situation where someone asked you that
question and it's nice if you'd answer
it had it get satisfaction surveys for
I'm just going to talk to them um
honestly servations foreign you're lucky
if you get ten percentage of responses
just go to their office how'd it go how
do you feel when what we do better sorry
the screen froze there we go um so
instructors you can use mediocre or
inexperienced teachers um picture down
at the bottom that was me that was me
really long time ago um i was teaching
surgery that
I've been in the field for less than
three years oh and I was able to be
moderately effective at it but it's
because the program that I was part of
realized my limitations and used me
appropriately so they relied on other
materials on nowadays we rely a lot on
videos extra resources I can't convey
the information well so give out
handouts use online things conferences
like this things like better bioscience
Institute things like a last learning
libraries youtube there is so much good
material is a lot of really bad material
but there's lots of good instructional
material on you slide them use them
transfer the information that way if
your teacher sent there to an experience
to do it effectively themselves
standardized things all your trainers
are teaching the same thing give them
structure allow them to execute a
program flexibility is wonderful in a
teacher but if you're not experienced
enough to convey it well that's how you
get into traps you teach things that are
incorrect to get your students into
trouble um you focus on results did
their animals live where they pain-free
with the procedure is successful you
know what maybe izing an experienced
teacher that's not how I would have done
that subcutaneous pattern but it worked
and I may not know enough to realize
that there are hundred different ways to
do it and your student did a perfectly
acceptable one but since I've never seen
it before to me it looks full make set
those expectations up front don't be
afraid to tell the stakeholders in the
process my training crew is relatively
inexperienced they're relatively young
it's okay but tell people what you're
dealing with and like your stakeholders
know what they're going to be dealing
with that they don't have surprises
facilities researchable stations that
are watch the app are they available for
training or they always in use if you
reserve them are you going to get bumped
it happens a lot I reserve training this
critical project it
so take those into account are there
locks that I can set up no one uses
these on Thursday afternoon that's what
we're doing training are they well
maintained or even walk in there and
have to budget now or just clean the
place up before you can control turn
ative can do things in procedure rooms
can you do cadavers and neat prophecy
what options do you have the facility
space itself is little what mminton the
same thing is available can actually get
to it can reserve it if you reserve it
will it actually be there maybe you're
going to get lucky maybe your students
use that equipment all day is a vast
majority of your students you're not
training them on a new procedures
something that they've been doing then
you're just validating that they're
doing it to your own internal standards
maybe you don't have to teach me how to
use that syringe pump or how to use that
as very attached device is it the same
as in their lab I used to make this
mistake a fair amount until it finally
beat me on the num that I saw I would
train people on equipment and they go
back to their lab I was so proud of my
shiny new equipment which is great until
they have to go back and work with
something that's 15 years old in their
lab and outside of basic function didn't
match when I tried them or at all are
there backups something breaks is your
whole training session wash if there's
something you can substitute in do you
know where is again questions to ask
yourself what I really talk about a lot
when I trained my own trainers and set
yourself up for success stack the deck
have everything ready so things can go
wrong and your students don't notice
because you have interesting animals do
you have the species and strain
available um I've done a lot of teaching
with surgery in dogs and non-human
primates and they're not just sitting
around and they're difficult to use for
training so again there are ways that we
can work around that but you need at the
outset to go you know what I can't use
30 non-human primates cinema August
monkeys for my training program or
student can't afford it they're not
available and quite honestly it's really
bad news event allies can use cadavers
our cadavers available it does you no
good to teach basic surgery on a cadaver
because as the mold upon it and they're
harvested for tissues and therefore more
than they're useless to you ki
substitute more available species and
strains of these Arab cadaver instead of
a live priming or suturing or tensor
dissection or what Hannah the three RS
which will avoid using them there is a
ton of stuff out there that you can use
for a lot of this training that doesn't
require you to use animals 3d met as a
whole series of wonderful suture place
and silicone molds and all the rest you
can use there are journal articles out
there for casting skulls and resin and
using those for stereotaxic approaches
so we don't have to euthanize animals
for no reason protocols what are you
going to do the sun do you have a
training protocol are you going to use
study protocols because how many times
with those of you who've been doing this
for how many times have we had protocols
not written yet because we hired this
person to bring this new capability on
walls so they're still writing the
protocol you can't train under a
non-existent protocol maybe you can if
you have a training protocol what are
you going to use for all this when
someone comes to you and says I want to
do something that has never been done in
this company before how will you set it
up so you can get them working as
quickly as possible with the level of
veterinarians i can use section area or
set can you use a veterinary consult to
work around some of these roadblocks
hopefully but you need to have those
answers up front supplies they can be
expensive seizure is not cheap are they
even available
can or should you use substitutions on
their financial partner what is your
program going to cost because I can tell
you that many of us have set up will
seem like really wonderful programs they
were really internally expensive and the
year or two down the line when you're
vice president or your director is
asking you why are you spending fifty
thousand dollars on a training program
you better have an answer and more
importantly you need to spend it maybe
you did but have an answer upfront and
discuss it with your BP and your
director have thereby and have them on
board before they get in sticker shock
references their pre-existing once again
Joe youtube dei virtual lab conferences
etc reference books presentation lots of
presentations if you ever are stuck for
especially when it comes in and see if
you handle cheese IAM most major state
universities have all of their stuff
online use it don't send the serial
numbers off please as someone who has
both seen it and experienced it you're
going to use someone's resources and at
least a tribute don't salmon serial
numbers on which name on it and say i
developed a 70-page you know anesthesia
book but within those constraints use
them but then create your own in maría
in my current orbit we make a lot of
training videos they save so much fun
they save so many animal ones if i
demonstrate the surgical procedure on
the video i use two or three animals it
takes the amount of time but then I
never have to demo it again what
students can watch it at their lesser so
when they show up for hands-on training
they're ready they've seen it they don't
have to sit there for half now we're
watching me do it I would have to spend
an hour setting up for a show up make
your own sheet sheets your own flow
charts here's how the procedure works to
dismiss them to guess use this suture
quick your reminders in
we do a lot of stuff with internet
presentations we have teaching modules
they are a huge help use them once you
can answer these questions then then you
can design your program because now you
know the parameters now you know the
constraints now you know the resources
you know the students you know the types
that you're going to be dealing with you
know the levels of experience they are
going to bring to the table you know the
levels of experience that you're
bringing to the table put all of that
together and oftentimes your program
comes into focus pretty quickly because
those constraints are going to set the
boundaries you're going to set the
structure they're going to set the
borderline if you don't have those and
your guests don't guess maybe you'll be
better at it than I am that I will tell
you that typically when I guess I guess
we're all and there's a loop it takes
you a week to set it up properly where
you spent months trying to fix it and
we're going to stakeholders one of the
biggest mistakes I see people make not
just in setting up a program but in
administering it is it will talk to
stakeholders stakeholders in your group
necessarily it's not your VP it's not
your director it's not your managers not
the rest of the training step
stakeholders are the people who are
depending on you to train their
personnel you get to work in their lives
they're paying that person a lot of
money it's do work for them they are the
stakeholders they're the people that you
should be involved in this process I
wouldn't recommend going to talk to them
before you answer these questions
because then if there's any pushback you
can little argument I have no data if
you do not have it then you have data
then you can have a real discussion
here's what I can do here's what I have
here's what I can accomplish so what
transparency comes in don't over promise
under Franz let them know what's going
on left and Melva constraints let them
know the problems be honest with them
because nothing makes a stakeholder and
I've had people reporting I
then that stakeholder I don't want to
find out two months into the process
that there's been a problem is too late
fix it where we've ways the two months
of my new hire start my time my research
is dependent on them I justify that
musician based on the work that they're
going to do and even to be doing it
don't forget that don't stalk internal
after the people you're doing the work
more so you've done all of that with any
luck you have a DC program well it takes
a couple of examples take the extremes
first example we've got two trainings a
year they work in my group they work in
my department I schedule their time so
they're available whenever I want them
to be and I've got two personnelles
trainers and one is really experiencing
what is fairly inexperienced in example
2 I get 50-plus trainees a year and
they're scattered throughout the company
they work a whole host of different
departments and many of them are higher
rank within the org chart and my
trainers or me um and they're not
dedicated training staff they're also
responsible how many kinds of all of us
st. they're not just trainers they're
also surgeons they are also running
their own studies they're also doing
their own research and let's make it a
little bit more complicated your
trainers are relatively great um you
can't spare the really experienced
people you're using the people who've
been doing surgery or maybe five years
those are going to require weekly
different approaches because they're
different and they're going to define
the purpose of the program if you have
all those can you design what fits best
oh you're going to maximize the impact
of your most available resources and
also your least available resources if
structures are right get in the picture
everything falls apart and it always
takes more time to fix something and it
tastes build it properly in the first
place
again I've been corporatized over the
years I apologize in advance but some of
the buzzwords really do matter and
mission statements matter and clarify
the goal of your program and then force
you can think it's easy to come up with
a 17-page proposal but if you have to
define everything that your training
program is going to do in one two three
sentences it is too complicated for you
to do that and it's probably complicated
enough that it's going to be really
really Anjali so it's going to clarify
things and also you can give that to
your stakeholders they now know your
mission stable so here are two we're
going to Train surgeons to perform
advanced procedures independently
minimal veterinary supervision that's
one second we're going to efficiently
trained surgeons for common surgical
procedures you appropriate aseptic
technique and surgical skills that's
going to result in completely different
approaches inside them if you look at
the first one I'm training independent
surgeons so I can't just train them on a
couple of receipts and allow them to
just follow that flow chart adjust to it
by rote as long as they don't deviate
from what we set they're probably going
to be okay they have to be able to think
through problems they have to be able to
do method development um that's going to
take a lot of timing better get really
really engaged students or none of that
will work but a lot of us have programs
that focus more on the other side eye
surgeons that I'm training are going to
do a fairly limited number of procedures
and what I need to do is I need to
compare them to do that well to maintain
decent aseptic technique these and
surgical skills to get good data out the
far end and good animal welfare but they
don't have to be stellar surgeons and
one of the things I made early on is
because I'm surgical elbow surgery
there's a reason of doing it this fall
and so you couldn't get me enough
training give me another opportunity I
want to take advantage of it you have
another reference
I want to read it and I tried to train
early on my training career people were
just like that and when they're not it
doesn't work and perhaps more
importantly they didn't need it they
don't have to learn everything there is
to know about surgery because they're
not going to use those skills again to
them is a tool if you stereotaxic
injections into lateral ventricle it
gets my compound into the brain and then
I see what happens stereotype is just
means to an end and I'm not going to be
doing additional types of procedures and
maybe in four or five years when I need
to I'll come back for more training so
for that first one fairly
straightforward set up your skill set
requirements change voice what do they
need to learn what time table do you
want them to learn it on set up your
standards what are your competency
criteria honey know that they've been
successful what are your resources
what's their availability and then
schedule them put them in assign the
training sessions documents
appropriately and off you go example too
much for your an assembly line person
but you're an assembly line teaching
people really delicate sometimes
challenging skills and you may have a
mixed program where some of those people
are going to have to be high level
surgeons you can be more difficult both
because of the throughput and because
your training resources are going to be
concerned you'll never have enough to
run that program the way you optimally
would like but that's okay because I
mean that it can't be affected what are
your most constrained resources and that
is almost always train or a training
time because you got to put them in the
same room together so never mind the
fact that both of them are busy it's
difficult to draw them in they also have
to sync up their challenges that can put
them physically in the same room for
those of us who've done it you'll know
that can be a real challenge to going
happen push as much out of those
sessions
what can you do that doesn't require
student in a trainer city that our room
together with those written standards
together have that training progression
give it to the students give it's the
managers they know exactly what they're
importing or what the commitments are
and they know what they are committing
to don't leave it open-ended don't even
let them know and you just be there
every week or it will require 10
sessions with me to get through on this
procedure so if you come in twice a week
we'll get you through in a little over
one come once a month it's going to be a
year set that up ahead of time again
transparency transparency transparency
be honest this is what it's going to
take this is what I do what you need how
can i accomplish that in and accomplish
that if you don't talk if you're a black
box your roadblock because all the
student sees is this person isn't
getting me through the processing I am
NOT getting to work in my lab is getting
upset with me I'm not holding up my
weight proving myself and that
relationship can go sour really quickly
so okay back straight all you know it's
difficult to train people and procedures
I've done eight classes when it comes to
actual surgical technique I'm not a fan
of it I personally feel that if I have
more than three maybe four students at
any one time not giving any of them
enough attention now if I'm validating
experienced surgeons that might work but
if their new surgeons are these some new
techniques they're sitting in the room
with me but I'm really not teaching
because I just don't have the time I'm
holding too many directions the more
things you can set up didactic anything
here's how you set up an M species here
are these standards for post-operative
care assessments let me hasten to add
that takes focused training but here's
what you need to look for here the
generalities what are your accepted
practices what are accepted practices
many of your students never heard that
work on one of the regulations how do
you do basic instrument handling what
are the basic EDS
that's how you sterilize etc but if you
are sitting in a room and you can
present to that many people then stop
wasting your time make a video of it
find a way to make that available
because even if you can batch drink 10
students in a two-hour lecture it's
still two hours of your time it could be
better served doing that one-on-one ends
on training it's also more difficult for
this deep because it's two hours that
they have to make to be in the same room
together I am a huge fan of online
training resources it's better for you
as a trainer because it preserves your
scarce fun once you set it up it's done
but also for your students they can do
it when they have natural gaps in your
schedule it works for everybody and
again if you can't do that put together
presentations do handouts I mean yes
videos and online modules are probably
be watching them but it can't do that
that's fun put it out there and again
youtube Joe other things about videos or
to teach them how to do a basic suture
technique their loss of good videos I
use those extensively watch this now
you've seen it now we can go to the
hands on it also lets me jump in quickly
students who are interested in what you
have teach them don't want to sit listen
to your talk they want to get their
hands in there we want to get to work
they want to learn the skills they don't
want to watch someone else do them so
here they wash it to get that exposure
they've seen the procedure then they
actually get to get to work and that's
for more rewarding for students than
listening to you talk in conference room
for three hours again your constraints
don't have enough trainers there are too
many people going through for you to
really focus on them so allow students
to practice on their own set up the
training so that we're going to learn
basic suturing they're going to work
with me going to go over and then as
soon as you're good enough to practice
independently off you go practice on
your own when you can fit it in the
schedule
and then come back to me when you hit
certain milestone and it's also
incidentally is great we email process
because lots of people one open surgery
but not a lot of people comparatively at
least are going to be doing it but it's
cool and they want to learn it is a good
resume builder and when you set them off
on their self study and it's going to
take 15 hours of their time you need out
serious students from the unser is
pretty darn quickly Oh again instead of
those references can do the videos that
you look like this and when you're
setting up your training scan that just
come together their tricks and so on
that they can use to assessment so give
them that upfront and then let them go
off and practice on their own and it
puts the responsibility on it but it
also gives message control back again
all about them student anything that's
not assisting this you learn and get to
work it's a waste of time it is
available in the system are your
training resources again put a trainer
to training room together get the most
bang for your lock focus on the
essentials focus on the things you can't
do any other way and again given the
updates track how are they doing how
long they've been in there how many
sessions etc etc record keeping is
critical because someone will ask you to
justify why did it take so long if you
didn't record that the student was
struggling with a technique you have no
way to justify why maybe it's a longer
or what they get through so quickly when
my last person did you thought all that
work wonderful no you have to make it
better and then we have to maintain it
your program working where can you
improve it again the benchmark is your
students are they successful in their
lab or do they require retraining it's
go back and ask because if the training
isn't setting them up to do the work
successfully in their lives and that's
something that you need to learn to take
back into your own training program my
own personal opinion if you're setting
students lose
to require retraining in their lab
you're not preparing them well and
you're wasting their laps on Retraining
them if you think that's not building
resentments on their lab mates part left
to vote their own scares time to retrain
the person who's been signed off on the
procedure by the training who's probably
use a bit of a roadblock anyways you're
not making friends are you keeping
metrics are you assessing your training
staff are seeking feedback and assessing
the program or improving your numbers
just your foot better is your time to
sign off going down is more cost of the
program going down use the animals go
down these are things you can measure in
these are painted almost always you can
improve I apologize and from New England
of a Patriots fitted oh but I like Tom
Brady in the red shirt because he
practices all quarterbacks all
professionals practice a lot your
trainer scrambles really practice
teaching are you giving them resources
to get better or you just kept the move
saying no your trainer good luck to you
don't screw any of your students up are
you making your trainers better than
that should be part of your program how
are you making better instructors are
you preventing drift if you use example
to where I've got 425 instructors and
either ever and will train together at
the end of the year how do I know that
they're still teaching same things in
the same ways to the same standard
students don't build if I have an
instructor deviate and besides that
gentle tissue handling isn't that
important you know what it takes up a
lot of time so I'm not in focus on it
you've lost that for your program or
what if your trainer your instructors
risk in a positive direction basically
you've got a better way to teach this or
the standards are higher we're being
communicated or that bit would you like
to capture that for all of your other
instructors fine and stuff out looking
to your students the cliche it there are
no bad students there are not a lot of
them I
that very few I've been very blessed by
the people that I've had the trade over
the years but by the same token 900-plus
yet I've had a couple um it just weren't
going to make it i had students who i
could not sign off her surgery um
usually though i found that students
that I would consider bad it just
unmotivated it's not that they couldn't
do it it's that they don't want to um
and again it may be they have no
interest in this or maybe their boss has
told them I want you learn how to do
this and you'll never use it but what
the heck it will be good for you have to
invest in it oh you have a way to deal
with that you have a way to communicate
that how do you explain to their boss
why you're not signing off I'd explain
to their boss that you're not letting
off someone according the resume is
doing surgery for 20 years that's a
tough position search rate or beat have
figured out how to do that the
conversely listen to if you have a
student who's struggling ask them what
is wrong what could I do to be a more
effective teacher for you listen to the
messed-up questions I like students to
challenge I've learned a lot on by the
same token depending on your experience
level I can handle challenges from
student now that there's no way I could
enable ten years ago no way after they
handle 20 years ago I would have choked
up at no answer but the nice thing is
that they challenge you you either know
the answer you give it to which means of
communicating information on better
training or you don't know the answer
that'll look it up because you should
have known that anyways in I have sanded
off a lot of rough edges of my own
surgical technique over the years
because someone thought we going to do
something and maybe was something small
and I never questioned it and we're
assuming funny that I look at it I
realized I shouldn't be doing it or
there's a better way to do that those
challenges make you a better surgeon
nevermind a better trainer oh if i'm
wrong i should change it if I student
has better idea
some changes so this is my personal
favorite example of this on one of my
senior people had a previous place of
employment Renee was going through
training and she had real gifts at
surgeon which also had a really
analytical mind so if you look at this
basically have a mountain in stereotaxic
set up as I SAT flooring going through
the blue tube to little nose home that
comes out of the way too and I spent ten
years I wish I was lying the ten years
forcing my students to work to the
stopwatch your nest eyes your animal ice
point you got 45 to 60 seconds to get
them in this I can your cars in the
stereo tax advice to get the eyes of
flying to the murder gonna wake up and
it was held for really hard putting an
animal scary tax is a top scale
especially a mouse or even wrap and so
they threw anything lower than a large
slice out there with grenades look at it
she looked instead of that dumb I looked
at her and I'd like to thank to my
credit I went wide and she looked down
and she said why can just move this nose
cone over them whenever they wake up let
them go fully back sleep and then i can
continue root system I don't have to
keep taking them out rien s sizing than
the change wedding than that I wanted
her an amount drop slightly open and I
realized she's absolutely right ever
since then I teach that to my students
it's so much easier but had I not been
willing to listen to her head I just
shut her down I never would have learned
that that's only one tiny piece of me as
a teacher that was improved that blessed
was really good students was with humans
to it what I'm saying is clear doesn't
make sense it challenged me and they
should because i'm a send them off to
work in if I tell them to do something
that's wrong they're gonna do it all if
I tell them something that doesn't make
sense they won't be able to do it
effectively but again less experienced
teachers can't handle that level and
that's okay I'm sure 10 years now be
able to handle challenges from suits
that I can't handle now
get back to the training that also gets
back to listen to more students so what
does this mean overall your training
staff is critical and I always leave
this when I trained in trainers and some
of it is to just scare the heck out of
them I admit it but some of it honestly
is because I really do believe this and
I think most of the good teachers and
trainers out of it I'm blessed with a
fantastic training staff a training
coordinator Sabrina my principal and
Bebo trainer drawn with searchable
trainer Jen taking on a ton of work your
forms are fantastic and they have the
same mentality you as a trainer are
going to have a massive impact on an
individual's career and a success in
their lab and their success in your
career is you're in first person
training them you're setting the
standard you're giving them their
foundation if you're a good teacher you
make good scientists if you're mediocre
teacher but you have a well structured
program you can make good scientists if
you're bad teacher if you don't want to
be in there or you're not taking this
seriously that foundation that you're
giving your student is all I try to
earlier of a falling apart OH that's
what you're doing and I have seen it
I've had students have been doing things
and they had arable teachers long long
time some of them we've been able to
work with get them to where they ideally
should have been some of them can never
overcome that and i have seen surgeons
who probably could have been really good
at that's where mediocre have possibly
dropped out of it um you are about to
have a tremendous impact on the careers
and really the science that your
students are going to do don't take it
lightly it's important and with that i'm
done put their questions comments or
concerns we are going to run through and
Angela um so I'm going to run down the
list of
please continue to put more of them
amount so surgeons fatigue is the first
one so the question is how do you do
something question is hey Thank You mr.
fleegle for your presentation Corey
lighter for our audience on how to
submit questions simply typed it in the
Q&A box found aw found by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window mr. flibble
will answer as many questions as time
permits so let's hop over and take a
look at the questions and rusty the
first question asked today how do you
deal with surgeon fatigue okay of
surgeon fatigue so there are a couple of
different ways to approach that um one
is the actual fatigue and there are so
many things in here that you can spend
hours talking about the ergonomics are
so important I focus on them and my
training again it's a buzzword that I
used to laugh at but I will tell you in
my early stages of teaching and I didn't
focus on it I've had students who washed
out of surgery not because they would
have been capable because itís teacher
didn't know enough t somehow not hurt
themselves so positioning your hands in
neutral positions stabilizing your
forearms keeping your shoulders and
arrested neutral position um taking
breaks there's a whole series of pieces
on it that you could address but most
basic way I can do for searching fatigue
is neutral shoulder position lots of
praise arms should be braised ideally
and should be braised teach good
instrument fundamentals teach how to
hold an instrument in what I call living
fashion which means they can flexibly
move throughout you
or hand is a huge advantage um it sounds
trite but the most basic will I teach my
teach search for ergonomics is in the
Kurtz probably shouldn't do it and you
should find an alternative way to do it
um by the same token especially large
animal surgery where typically are
standing it's going to be exhausting all
again walk around moves don't let your
joints lock up don't rest your weight on
your forearms I would really focus on
the ergonomics of it and start them off
early the very first hands-on training I
get when I got students is that hands-on
how you hold an instrument how to
manipulate it how do you figure out a
neutral grip how do I keep my shoulders
and getting string how do I avoid
excessive risk rotation and pronation
and what have you focus on the
ergonomics that's my best dancer for
that thank you for that thank you for
that answer do you have any information
on how to transmit life to recover from
surgery do they recover worse than other
minds so my best answer to that is yes
no maybe what I mean by that is where
I've worked especially when I was
working at genzyme we were almost
universally a transgenic shop and
transgenics some of them are
significantly harder than others and
unfortunately until you've worked with
that particular strain you don't know um
by and large I have found that
genetically manipulated animals tend to
be less robust um they don't reach well
recover as well with mice in particular
keep them warm keep them oxygenated um
it's credible net oxygenation is
critical especially if you're using
injectables I've been blessed with it
take direct reports and staff over the
years and several years back one of my
senior people Theresa hit a wonderful
series of experiments where she measured
the effects of putting around one
hundred percent oxygen with injectable
anesthetics short version of this it was
in an academy of surgical research
presentation i believe is available
online but the short version of this is
you let that animal brief room air let's
say a ketamine xylazine acepromazine
cocktail their o2 saturation drops down
into the high 50s low 60s and up 15 to
30 seconds which if you were in a
veterinary clinic in un animal
presenting that way you put them on
immediately it's a life-threatening
emergency so there are times that I'm
amazed that our animals survive at all
for the monitor aha sorry one hundred
percent oxygen their o2 saturation jumps
98 about 10 seconds you tell your way it
drops getting 15 and 30 so yes commonly
transgenic mice don't recover as well
they have prolonged recovery times they
are more sensitive to complications
afterwards I've seen them where there's
a higher incidence or dehiscence so your
closure is important using things like
tissue adhesive properly can be a huge
help but yeah recovery I tend to run
them on lighter and setec dose if it's a
talent or if it is an injectable app
using ejectable I put them on oxygen and
keep them on heat and for heaven's sakes
with mice again most of us you probably
already know this and I apologize for
telling you things you already know what
a recirculating game has to diddly-squat
there's barely any heat transfer but
they're relatively chetan we use them a
lot on warm air blowers again it seems
excessive but if you have a transgenic
males for each one's for five hundred
dollars boy the cops attacking unit
suddenly seems a lot more reasonable
electric heating plates immersive
beanbag style ones like shoreline used
to make
use them so yeah I tend to see them
recover more slowly although some of
them surprise me so it's what you're
doing during the anesthetic procedure
that won't kind of save you honestly
save them as well
thank you our third question for the day
apps I do decapitation IV infusion in
minor surgery how do i improve after a
long time how do i improve after a long
time with no employment in the field so
that's a good question oh that's a
really good question it's also a really
hard question it's good news is actually
a fair amount you can do depending on
your focus generalized surgical
knowledge is essential so if you have an
internet account which obviously do
because you're watching this google to
research there's so much material on the
University website there's so much for
free that is mouth hair so learn the
basics of aseptic technique look through
the things that are on university
websites oh there's a whole host of
materials and before I get too much
deeper into this at the end they will
giving you contact information please
feel free to pass on and they'll put you
and I in touch and there's more that we
can do but i will tell you do the
research learn if you have that type of
knowledge then it will help you
tremendously learn physical skills for
the physical skills instrument handling
verga nomics dexterity on purpose will
show up to well companies of 10 for this
it's going to sound silly get pair of
scissors grab one from around your house
and just get used to manipulating them
back and forth get your fingers in the
Rings Tom the instrument move it back
and forth transfer transfer to the other
hand these types of basic instrument
dexterity exercises will be a huge
godsend for um beyond that again go to
youtube go to joe arm
things like this like this conference on
the internet there's ton of really good
video out there that will talk you
through how to do it now the sticking
point is going to be being able to get
in and practice those techniques but a
lot of things basic suturing and
dissection your practice basic
dissection get an exacto blade go to
your hobby shop of your hardware store
practice on things like skin two chicken
breasts um you can both make your meal
and practice your surgical techniques in
the same time it is the same scale
you're still learning dissection oh
you're still learning incision creation
if you want to suture is it optimal to
be practicing with me Orleans resident
nope what can you learn the basics of
suture patterns and kind of great things
together absolutely um is it better to
train with needle holders sure it is um
if you have a hobby shop around
especially a model store amazing from
many surgical instruments they're really
cheap ones that still searching for
instruments in design you can buy for
ten fifteen twenty dollars and i'll send
you can practice your suturing you can
practice your kids your data section
considering how much i push my students
using those resources you get a lot out
it just because you're not in the field
doesn't mean that you don't have the
ability to learn a tremendous amount
about surgery so there you go but yeah
i'm reaching the contact at the end and
there's more that we can work on I would
be happy to help
if there are no more questions today I
would like to once again thank you to
thank mr. legal for his presentation do
you have any final comments today why
wats loves final comments but at the
interest of time the people being able
to get on with their day just a couple
so one is you're setting up a program
think about all the constraints that we
talked about early on have those
questions answered before you create
your structure um the other piece is if
you're a teacher please take it
seriously the inductor you're going to
have on your students lives can be
really profound and you can change
people's careers tab all of us have been
teaching this for a while have had
people who had no interest in surgery
you've got a hold of them and suddenly
their whole career in many cases for the
rest of their lives um don't take that
lightly they're putting a lot of
themselves into your hands so please
take it seriously and do the best you
can for them if you can do that you're
probably going to be a pretty good
teacher oh and that would be about it
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today we would also like to
take glabrous for today's educational
web task this webcast can be viewed on
demand to remain 2017 libraries will
alert you via email when it is available
to replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's web event I'll see you
next time here at labrys com goodbye